hi everyone so we're gonna start the
armed up a couple report so the task so
for this bake-off we had to do were
level natural language and ferns with
binary classification so basically we
want to be predicting on the word
entailment given two words
so we had a disjoint train and train
test split which reflects our
expectation that we want to be able to
generalize on unseen words and go caps
so our evaluation data set consisted of
1767 negative labels and 146 positive
labels which is a pre unbalanced data
set and thus our evaluation matrix was
macro f1 score so on some people
actually put it there microwaved one or
the weighted f1 but we only looked at D
on the microwave one the microwave one
and the way to that one were a bit
higher than the intended on that correct
one and my craft one is at this
desirable matrix because um because of
tailing balance so this is histogram of
the submission scores as you can see on
the baseline is right around 0.67 and as
you can see all people were able to
surpass the baseline which is really
good as usual we're gonna look at the
arm the VSM results for top-performing
models and the arm the less significant
ones so on for the tops of missions so
as you can see the cool of embedding was
being used very frequently and as you
can see from the variable names such as
torched a tensor arm you can see that
they probably played around with your
own network frameworks and this probably
doesn't have to do a lot with the design
but um the puffs of missions they had
young the variable name custom
experiment a lot which we thought was on
pre interesting and let's take a look at
the arm the bottom performing models as
you can see there are a lot of numbers
which probably means that people hadn't
picked typer parameters and again as you
can see the the variable name word this
joint experiment of program were in Nam
the bottom submissions and in tough
submissions all right and so on the
first place goes to group 26
congratulations on they got the score of
0.7
five - is group 26 here and what they
did what they used a combination of
birth sequence classification model with
over sampling so on they use transfer
learning they used the pre trained bird
on and to end sequence classification
model and then they trained on our
training data set and tested on the
evaluation set and in order to account
for the data imbalance they use over
sampling specifically on the random over
sampler they randomly sample with
replacement on the current available
samples to make to balance out the on
the label distribution and the second
place goes to group 9 in scream 9 here
congratulations on you got the score of
0.75 or 1 so what they did was they use
Facebook in-person model and they
pre-trained the impressive model on the
SNI
the Stamper and oli corpus dataset and
they transfer the weights and then they
added an extra layer at the end where
binary classification and or the UM data
imbalance problem they use weighted loss
and they say they set the weights to one
and five point three meaning that they
gave five times more emphasis to class
110 class Europe so on the both these
two submissions the top first in the top
second they use transferring and some
type of way to balance out that they
didn't balance which was really
impressive moving on we also looked at
the model song that performed the worst
and we figured out some things that
didn't really quite work so first of all
arm element wise multiplication is not a
good function to combine vectors and for
this task
jellow networks linear linear
regressions or svms did not work as well
as the deep neural classifiers this is
kind understandable because on board
this task it's really hard to UM
handcraft DM the feature representations
okay um that's all I have any questions
all right Thank You men that was cool I
guess a few comments about that so first
the same team that won this time one
bake-off two as far as I know that's
unprecedented that the same group won
two bake-offs although I do remember
that Lucy and jayadev on separate teams
last year finished in the top two or
three on two of the Bake off's which is
also very impressive but it's striking
that the same team won and I believe
that they won with broadly the same
approach which is burnt with some
task-specific fine-tuning and then a few
other tricks that are specific to the
data set and that's pretty cool next
week we're going to be talking about
bird and Elmo and the transformer and
that might give us some insight into why
those techniques are working so well so
stay tuned on that the other thing I
wanted to say is just I mentioned this
last week it's really cool now that a
bunch of you have done really serious
work on four separate and LU tasks you
developed custom models for them some of
the things that you did are incredibly
ambitious and I just think that's cool
in terms of you having experiences to
report and now experiences to draw on
when you go forth and do your own
projects so congratulations do you all
the plan for this week is to try to do
things that will be like directly
relevant to your projects whatever they
are because it's it's it's kind of
awkward to be introducing new topical
material now when we know that you all
are probably focused on whatever special
thing that you're doing for your own
projects but this is a nice moment in
which to start talking openly about
methods and metrics and things like that
because the next major assignment that
you have to do is this new document that
we're calling an experimental protocol
which is replacing the kind of milestone
document that we have used in years past
so in years past you did the lit review
and then the milestone was a kind of
generic check-in and it was kind of an
attempt to make sure that you were
working steadily on the projects what
we've what we're trying to do with this
new approach to this interim report is
kind of save you from yourselves to make
sure that you're incrementally working
on these projects but also to kind of
modify our belief that it's valuable to
be doing a particular kind of
quantitative evaluation and also
encourage you to start talking in a
detailed way with your teaching team
mentor about exactly how the project
should be structured what kinds of
experiments you could be running what
kind of additional data you could bring
in and so forth so let me just walk
through this to make sure it's clear
kind of what we're expecting it's due on
the 27th
it's a highly structured report in the
sense that you could just copy out these
prompts if you wanted to and fill them
in you don't need to invest in writing a
nicely structured paper I think it would
actually be valuable for the team if you
kind of stuck to this framework because
in turn this is the framework that we're
going to use as a kind of rubric to
evaluate the work so right off the bat
we want you to state hypothesis or
hypotheses I think that this is often
not done or not done enough in NLU and
NLP and one reason that I can make that
inference is that in recent years if you
review for ACL they have started
codifying exactly this requirement in
their referee form so as a reviewer
you're meant to state back to the
authors and to the area editors exactly
what the hypotheses are to kind of get
everyone thinking about whether or not
the paper is doing something beyond just
throwing a bunch of parts together and
running a quantitative evaluation so we
want you to state your hypothesis these
hypotheses can take many forms and this
will depend a lot on what kind of
project you're doing it could be
something as simple as my hypothesis is
that for my dataset the transformer is a
better model than an RNN at making the
relevant predictions right that would be
kind of functional kind of engineering
oriented but it is nonetheless a
hypothesis and if you reflect on why you
believe in your hypothesis that might
lead you to even deeper insights like
for my dataset which is structured in a
particular way the transformer has the
right kind of structure to reflect the
data something like that but it could be
quite functional and just describe what
kind of experiments you want to do but
it could be something as interesting as
I believe that in process
Project Gutenberg files I can tell
whether the author is a man or a woman
based on their portrayal of female
characters which is a really interesting
hypothesis from a past year that a
project team did I think it's one of the
ones we picked as the as a top project
right and that would be more Social
Sciences oriented and more at a remove
from the particular modeling tools that
they're using because they're just
saying like this is a signal that I can
detect using NLP tools and there's lots
of stuff in between those two extremes
the point is state it stated as clearly
as you can and start talking about it
with your mentor make sense then as you
can imagine coming in at second here
data we want a description of the
datasets it could be again as something
as simple as I'm using multi and a lie
or something as complicated as here's my
procedure for crowdsourcing a web
scraped custom data set that I developed
for this project for the first one it's
probably okay to just mention it and
give the relevant citation for the
second one I think it would be helpful
if you gave us some details on the
nature of the data set because for
example our suggestions for you are
going to vary depending on whether or
not you have five thousand instances
five hundred or five million and also in
turn like the internal structure of the
data set will matter so give us a clear
picture of that
then the metrics you'll state the
metrics that's going to be one of our
topics for this week these are going to
be the thing that forms the basis for
your quantitative evaluation if it's
familiar that's good right if you're
doing a classification problem within
balanced data easy to justify that
you're using macro f1 maybe harder to
justify micro f1 but maybe you want to
do it maybe harder still to justify
something like an imbalanced version of
the f1 score because you want a favored
precision or recall or if you're working
on something like dialog agents then as
you'll see today or next time this is a
tricky question exactly what metrics to
use because it seems to me that all the
available ones have their own faults and
so you might want to say I'm going to
use purple
city it has these known downsides but
then again for my project it's the right
thing because it fits intellectually or
you could just be upfront and say it's
expedient because I don't have any other
kind of extrinsic evaluation I can run
right just be open and upfront about
what choices you're making and why
that's the spirit of this and then we'll
give you a response like hey you know I
really feel you could go beyond your
chosen metric here's a slightly better
perspective on the problem or something
like that then models we want a
description of the models that you'll be
using and I think the thing to do here
is remember that we don't just want a
description of your favorite model the
one that you're kind of advocating for
but also a statement of which models
you'll be using as baselines because as
we're going to talk about a little bit
later today
none of these evaluation metrics really
have any meaning in isolation if you
were appoint a report of 0.76 for your
model just as a lonely number there
nobody has any idea what that means if
it's a familiar dataset maybe we can
fill in some background but then again
it should follow you to fill that in and
if it's an unfamiliar dataset we just
won't know so one thing you can do to
provide that context to set up some
baselines and I'm going to go over a
bunch of ways that you can do this where
the baselines maybe get more and more
ambitious but all of them will help us
in understanding what you achieved great
question yeah I think certainly at this
stage it's the more published numbers
you can provide the more context we'll
have we might encourage you also to fit
some of your own baselines especially if
the published numbers are astronomically
high because then you might want to say
like okay somehow teams that Google have
achieved point and I know because of
their vast resources but the competition
I'm running is between two more modest
models and mine still wins within that
space in which case your own baseline is
serving as a kind of given your budget
and time constraints and goals what the
baseline is
but I think those upper bound numbers
like top numbers in literature are great
human performance if you know it
information about inner annotator
agreement also valuable context for for
what we can expect for your data yeah
great question
others about the models this is kind of
the heart of it here and what we'll be
looking for this kind of leads into this
general reasoning part is a statement a
brief statement of how the data and the
models come together to inform your
hypothesis and we have this as a
separate item because we don't want you
to take it for granted we would like to
hear your version of why your data and
models and baselines are going to come
together to achieve this this is not
idle work because if you do this well
it's probably going to be the basis for
the abstract for your paper because this
is more or less what you want from an
abstract - maybe maybe the abstract has
some additional context and then we
would like a summary of your progress so
far so what have you done if you've run
experiments and they're all in and you
have confidence that's great preliminary
numbers are great what do you still need
to do obstacles that we helpful to raise
at this point things that we should know
that might be blockers for you and
getting all that you want to achieve
done by the time it's all due and then
don't forget this because we'll ding you
for it references section proper
bibliography I don't know because I
don't really think of the length as
having any kind of inherent virtues or
vices here how long would it take me to
answer these questions it could be as
short as a couple of pages right for
some projects where it's like my data is
SN L I my hypothesis is that the Potts
model is better than to some other model
my metric is going to be macro F 1 my
models I can sketch out the general
reasoning is clear like the Potts model
is keyed into n Li the way no other is
and here's why : you know here's the it
wouldn't take me very long
but if you're doing something quite
custom or you still have open questions
like I've talked with a few people who
maybe even it's unclear what metrics
they'll be able to use I think you might
devote more space to it any other
questions
all right
so I have what we're going to do for
this week is I have two notebooks that
I'm going to show you
they're both posted at the website they
both have code and I've kind of elided
elided the code for a lot of this
presentation but it's there for you if
you want to get more hands-on with the
material but the first one is going to
be on methods and the second one on
metrics the metrics one I might not do
too much lecturing about it's not the
stuff of really compelling lectures but
I would like to just broadcast to you my
framework for thinking about these
metrics and how you might choose your
own and think about your own and then
you can kind of use that notebook as a
reference and then more exciting on
Wednesday is going to give a short
presentation about what you might think
of as like the 2.0 version of the
traditional metrics and methods for NLP
where we go beyond the stuff that I'm
going to show you today and start
thinking in a more serious way about
what it means to truly generalize and
maybe to truly have like what we could
call understanding for a phenomenon or
or a domain or a task and I think that's
going to be really fruitful because you
all might want to push beyond like
reporting macro f1 scores and think
about what your systems have actually
learned and this is an opportunity for
you to do that
that kind of brings me to this overview
here so our primary goal is to talk
about projects I can't do methods or
metrics in a comprehensive way but I
hope I can give you a kind of foundation
for thinking about all these issues and
partly what I want to do is just bring
some of this out into the open because I
have a feeling that a lot of it is stuff
that you're supposed to just kind of
pick up on the streets
everyone kind of presupposes it and you
get a feel for what the issues are
how to navigate this and I was just
hoping we'd have an open discussion
about it basically and as I said that
brings me to the project so I want to
make a few things clear about how we
think about projects first we will never
evaluate a project based on how good the
results are we just make this font a
little bigger
oh only those arrows are getting bigger
I hope you can if not if it's hard to
read you can follow along at the website
all the stuff is drawn from that main
notebook and I'll read it aloud so just
to emphasize again we will never
evaluated based on how good the results
are I grant you that publication venues
have they do this whether they have to
is secondary but they do it and they do
it because they have constraints on
space that lead them to be only able to
publish a few things and then all of
science has a bias for positive evidence
for things over negative results that's
why you might get your paper rejected
because you don't have state-of-the-art
results even if you have wonderful
insights and analyses it's a sad thing
about the state of publishing and I
think it's true all over science but in
CS two to four you we are not subject to
that first constraint which means that
we can do the right and good thing of
valuing positive results negative
results and everything in between
right so just because you got what looks
like a state of the art number on your
data set does not mean that you'll get
an a triple plus and correspondingly if
your hypothesis totally falls flat but
you give a really stellar evaluation of
it and like maybe some insights into why
everything fell apart that could be an
A+ paper right so we're going to
evaluate you based on the
appropriateness of your metrics the
strength of your methods and the extent
to which you are open and honest and
clear-eyed about the limits of your
findings and other things like that and
I've been trying to push this on people
in office hours like because of that
first dynamic about publishing this is a
rare opportunity for you to try
something really wild and crazy and you
know something that would
just be too risky as a conference of
mission because you never know and
surely you know the really earth-shaking
ideas began as things that sounded too
wild and crazy' in fact my read on the
whole history of deep learning is that
it was too wild and crazy' for 30 years
before it wasn't so you never know right
so let's start walking through these
issues I think some of them seem obvious
but all of them are worth reflection I
would love to have your questions and
comments I would love for this to be a
bit of a dialogue here start with stuff
that's basic so data organization you
guys have heard about this we have like
the idea of a trained dev test split and
this is a common thing to see in large
publicly available datasets
even before diving into the details of
how this works as a community you should
reflect on the fact that even this is a
non-obvious choice right because in the
background here is an assumption that
you will develop a system using the
training and dev data and then evaluate
it on test data and the reason that we
draw those from the same body of
examples is we feel that that's in some
sense a fair evaluation that if my
system has learned its parameters on the
training data it ought to be able today
to generalize to data that is in some
sense from the same empirical
distribution as the training data and we
think of that as a kind of fair
evaluation it's not the only conceivable
approach that you could have to
evaluation and in fact you might think
it's kind of stacking the deck in favor
of all the systems and overstating all
of our results because you're given even
before you look at the test data a kind
of guarantee that you'll be looking at
similar examples and you can imagine
that the whole field took an alternative
route of saying our evaluations the ones
that will allow into our prestigious
publishing venues are all going to be
human subjects evaluations where humans
have to deal with a system and give
their ratings about whether their
systems are good or not and and we
wouldn't value the numbers that we value
in this course so much so even this is a
non-obvious choice and the other part
that might be kind of non-obvious about
this
is that the test data does come from the
same body of examples as the training
data and that's one where I can feel the
community kind of starting to push back
starting to acknowledge more and more
that this is overstating what our
systems can actually do and for example
in this course the multi and allied data
set is one that has the mismatched test
condition where you train on some genres
and test on genres that you've never
seen before that's starting to push back
on the core assumption that you're
seeing on this slide about train dev
test and I think people aspire to do
even more radical things to give up on
this the way people tend to state it is
training and testing on the same
distribution it's hard to know what it
would mean to test on a different one
because there's an infinitude of
different data sets that you could pick
and surely trying to generalize a system
trained on SNL I and testing it on
evaluating chairs and tables in the real
world right completely different data
that's going to fail what's in between
there that would be a more ambitious
test multi and Li as one gesture in that
direction but back down to earth many
data sets that you study will have this
kind of split and as we've emphasized
before you I you're on the honor system
to not use your test sets like the
paradigm for you if you're publishing is
that you're on the honor system to do
all your work on the train and dev sets
never looking at tests even if you
possess it and then just before
publication with all the systems done
you run a single test evaluation enter
the numbers into your document and
submit and you're just at the mercy of
what happened on tests I don't know how
often people really adhere to that it's
sort of scary to think about people
compromising that position and I think
that's one reason why you're seeing an
increased use of test sets that are
truly held out in the sense that they
are on Kaggle or held by a system and we
maybe even keep track of how many times
different teams are evaluating on that
test set yeah sort of mean that you you
wouldn't be able to analyze like how you
did on the test set ultimately like if
you're just running it and
submitting or you can't actually run it
while you're still writing your paper is
the idea that when you're discussing
your results you're discussing your dev
results that would be my preference
maybe people differ on this but my
preference would be that when you
discuss when you do error analysis you
do it on dev because of this last point
here this test set people start hill
climbing on it so if you publish a
wonderful paper with detailed detailed
error analysis on your test set then I
get to learn a lot about what works and
what doesn't even if technically I have
never peaked at the data set and in that
way we would just end up with a lot like
community hill climbing on the data so
my preference would be that these are
just kind of stark numbers that you see
even that's going to allow some hill
climbing because we can get a community
wide sense of what's working and what
isn't but yeah that's my preference good
totally different sets right like we're
testing on a different distribution
entirely is it there even not useful to
kind of talk about like say you know you
just do an easily worse on this new data
set like that seems kind of notable that
you would want to talk about like gosh
there was something in my model that
that sort of failed to capture this
difference uh-huh yeah that's a fair
point
if you think there's some value you
might like if you I mean if you're doing
the thing of just saying like hey this
system that was trained on Twitter I'm
going to apply it to the Wall Street
Journal and it falls down because the
styles are very different for that Wall
Street Journal data said I'm not even
sure whether you're thinking of that as
your final test set and it might be okay
because it's more qualitative but I
think it will depend on the
circumstances but if you're in this
hypothetical situation if you're
releasing that Wall Street Journal test
set and you want others to use it it
probably benefits you to be kind of
tight-lipped about it and maybe have a
dev or ssin that is keyed into that
other questions about this yes I see
that if your sort of class distribution
is across
sometimes you just arbitrary talking of
this you're raising a very important
issue yeah I agree with the core of it
we want similar distributions here but
this can get quite intricate as you can
imagine if we think about problems that
have different structures where I always
think that the really scary version of
this is what if your data set depends on
a knowledge graph then how are you going
to do this in a way that's fair and
these issues arise in more subtle form
and I'll show you some tools that help
you manage some of these problems but
you're absolutely right about the kind
of core default insight the other point
I wanted to make here is that even doing
this presupposes a pretty large data set
like if you do work in healthcare or
something where every example is kind of
hard one you might be reluctant to hold
out a test set because it really means
that you're giving up on a whole bunch
of data that could be used and studied
in an interesting way so that brings me
to this next thing here which would be
like no splits some public datasets
do have this property and I think this
can be good but it does pose a challenge
for assessment because for really robust
comparisons you have to run all the
models using whatever assessment regime
you've picked right so if does a bunch
of experiments on one of these data sets
and he splits in his way and I don't
maybe know the details of how he did
those splits and I do different splits
strictly speaking if I want to compare
our numbers now I can't quite do it
right because for a really fair
comparison we should be looking at
exactly the same splits because who
knows what happened when we did these
random divisions let me just say that
because I always want to balance this
that's the ideal and so the ideal is
that somehow I get from exactly his
splits or his model and I rerun
everything in a super careful way and
then my results table can be reported
with no caveats that's the ideal but of
course we don't live maybe in the ideal
world we all want to have room to say
unfortunately I couldn't get exactly the
splits that it's used so my compare
persons are informal in that sense but
nonetheless reliable and I think the
important thing is that you report them
and talk about their value but with that
caveat attached and that's very
different like if you think about
reviewers being your antagonists if you
just report these numbers without giving
context the reviewer might say thumbs
down those comparisons weren't fair it
wasn't the same splits if you give the
caveat and acknowledge it it's kind of
harder for them because you've already
contextualized the results that you're
offering yeah in a question you don't
have enough data then overfitting would
be the goal like if you had an all text
ever written that almost not be good to
just over fit to that in the sense that
you have so much data that if you fit it
well and you just kind of fit text well
like it's so large that it might as well
be as large as all other answers that
will ever be produced by humans I guess
is there sort of an implicit assumption
that no data set is too large that like
everyday to said it doesn't matter how
big it is you still need some something
that who's been held out in order to
evaluate it properly I think I do want
to stand by that I think language is so
complicated that you never see even but
the tiniest portion of the full
distribution of utterances were
incredibly creative with language we
produce entirely new utterances all the
time and that means there's always room
for testing generalization yeah that's
one of the exciting things about the
domain I would say that you could think
that like the entirety of wordnet stands
all the relations you might need to use
so maybe in that setting it's
appropriate to train and test on the
same data because really you're just
trying to encode relational information
and it doesn't really matter like you do
in general access oh I see so you don't
mean literally the same data but rather
just the same kind of data set that gets
split yeah in which case I think your
observation kicks in for sure if we're
looking at the dictionary of English
we might think that this is the entirety
of the domain yeah for large data sets
if they don't come with a predefined
split as part of your project you could
impose splits and just say like here's
what I'm gonna use and I don't look at
the test data this can be nice if you
have the luxury of doing this I would do
it because it simplifies your
experimental setup in many ways as
you'll see and in particular the second
point is important you'll see that for
very careful hyper hyper parameter
optimization you end up doing a lot of
evaluations and having fixed splits as
opposed to doing something like
cross-validation could dramatically
reduce the number of things you have to
do here and also just kind of yes
simplify lis like remove an inner loop
from your experiment code as you'll see
so I'd encourage you to do that and then
the qualifier there is just for small
data sets
you might feel too constrained to leave
out some data for testing and I'll talk
about strategies for strategies for that
next oh yeah that kind of brings me to
this other mode so cross-validation so
instead of having fixed splits and
cross-validation we take a set of
examples X and partition them into two
or more train tests splits an average
over the results in some way you
probably have heard about this before
there are two kind of classes of ways
you could do this the first one I'll
call random splits so in this case
shuffle your data hold out 10% of the
data for training probably the rest for
testing and run an experiment and then
make another split randomly run an
experiment and so forth and you can do
that as many times as you want
and you might want to do it a lot to get
some insight into how much variance
there is in your systems performance
relevant to that question in the back
I'm sorry I don't know your name but
this was a great insight that when I do
this I probably want to make sure that I
have the same distribution of labels
across the splits so psych it makes this
very easy the relevant code has a
keyword called stratified and you can
just make sure that you've told the code
to honor the distribution of the train
and test have them equal across all
these splits and I think
will lead to more consistent evaluations
you're good in the bad of random splits
okay so the good is that you can create
as many as you want without having this
impact the ratio of training to test
examples that'll become clear when we
look at true cross-validation but the
idea is that you can just run as many of
these experiments as you want because
probably with a large data set there
might as well be an infinite number of
ways that you could do these divisions
the bad is kind of related to that there
is actually no guarantee that every
example will be used the same number of
times for training and testing so
depending on the nature of the splits
that you do you might be looking at kind
of distorted evaluations as you combine
them an average them but this has really
nice flexibility to it and in situations
where your model is pretty fast to train
and test the fact that you can do lots
of splits this way without impacting the
ratio of trained to test examples is
very powerful it will open the door to
doing some testing of the statistical
differences of your systems let's
contrast that with oh and here's some
you know some code that you can use
psych it is as usual wonderful for
helping you do this kind of thing let's
compare this with k-fold
cross-validation this is different from
the random train test split thing so in
k folds you divide your data into what
are called k folds they're so different
sets here like fold one two three and
you conduct k experiments in each fold i
it's in each fold so it's sorry each of
the experiments fold i's used for
assessment and the other folds are
merged together for training so if I
have three folds here these are subsets
of the examples for experiment one I
holdout fold one trained on two and
three and tests and I get a number in
the second experiment I holdout to train
on one and three and I get a number so
forth for the third one here I test
unfold three and trained on one and two
so now I've seen every combination of
these three folds and I get three
numbers and I can average them or
something and maybe report if I do more
folds kind of confidence intervals
around those me
let's do the good in the bad here so the
good in the bad kind of complimenting
the last few every example appears in a
train set exactly K minus one times and
it's in the test set exactly once so
that's nice you have some guarantees
about how you've gone through the data
I'd say the bad of this is that the size
of K determines the size of the train
test splits so with three fold cross
validation you train on 67% of the data
and test on 33 but with 10 fold you
train on 90 and test on 10 those are
very likely to be different experiments
and Aereo's and I feel like two things
have gotten muddled together when you're
doing this on the one hand you wanted a
lot of runs because you wanted a real
sense for system performance across
different settings on the other hand you
end up changing the size of the training
and test data when you do that and
that's just a consequence of the good
here so it's not like we can blame the
method but if might steer you back
toward random splits where you don't
have this relationship and all you're
giving up on is this absolute guarantee
up here make sense and as usual as I
said psych it is great for this k-fold
and stratified k fold and then it has
these helper methods here cross validate
and cross Val score which will allow you
to set up models and datasets and kind
of under the hood do all these
evaluations so that you don't write
nested for loop code which is hard to
maintain and the only two tips I want to
make there is first when you use these
guys you might be explicit about what
your cv argument is so that you have
absolute certainty that you were doing
stratified if you want to or just k fold
if you don't if you're kind of nervous
like me and then maybe more important is
that when you do this you set the
scoring value if you don't set a scoring
value for these functions it's going to
default to whatever the models inbuilt
score is and for example for a
classifier that will be accuracy and
we've seen I think time and again
that's probably not the metric that we
want to be using for our evaluations so
you have to take this step of explicitly
changing that to macro f1 or whatever
your choice is yeah and just to mention
a few variants k folds has some special
cases against Ike it is good about this
so in leave one out leave one out cross
validation you actually this is an edge
case of K folds where I hold out just a
single example for testing and train on
all the rest and I do that Kate you know
for every the number of times that there
are examples in my dataset and average
the results you would do that if you
have a very small data set in the
relevant sense and there might be two
ways it could be small first you might
just have a tiny number of examples in
which case you'll be compelled to do
this the other situation would be that
maybe you have a very large data set but
you would like to conduct evaluation and
evaluation that is like at the level of
users and so maybe every user is
associated with a hundred thousand techs
and you have 12 users so you actually
have a quite large data set but if I
want to do this user level evaluation
suddenly the data seemed quite sparse
and in that case you might do they'll
leave one out thing and then finally
psych it has a function called leave P
groups out that's actually quite
sophisticated about helping you to do
splits that are not just the standard
ones so for example it has key word
things that you can do to make sure that
you split along a temporal dimension
which would be important for anything
with a time series aspect to it
I think you could also manage things
that needed to be divided by like a
demographic group or other things like
structure and your data that aren't
immediately evident from your labels in
which case you know if it's just the
labels then the stratified option will
probably take care of that good so
that's it for splits did I leave
anything out and talking about all this
stuff k-fold cross-validation stuff like
that yeah so
are putting forth like a trained model
would you ultimately train it on all the
data and then just use this
cross-validation as like an
approximation yeah probably not if if
you have a fixed test set then you
certainly won't do what you just
described I think I think you would do a
lot of cross validation as part of
development but then finally evaluate on
the test set so for example if your data
set has just trained test and no dev
then in place of dev you might do a lot
of cross validation runs inside the
training data to get a sense for exactly
how your system generalizes in all sorts
of ways that you can throw at it and
then evaluate on test I think you would
have these as your final evaluation
numbers only for data sets that don't
have a test set because they're smaller
they weren't released with one in which
case you know you get the benefits of
not having just one number
just this test that number because maybe
the test set was chosen very strangely
and it's distorting progress on the data
set it's kind of nice to know that we're
reporting the average of a bunch of
different runs gives us a sense of more
robustness on the other hand you don't
get that pristine kind of held out
nature of a test set other oh yeah
nutrition for the ratio between
it's a good question I don't know it I
feel like you see 80/20 7525 6733 but I
don't think there's much behind this
it's probably people just stepping back
and thinking like what's a good a large
enough number that the testing isn't
going to be kind of wild but also isn't
going to deny me too much training data
that's the best answer I can give it
certainly gets more interesting if you
think about holding out much more test
data how good can these systems get if I
show them only half the data for example
but as a data set creator you might be
shooting yourself in the foot by doing
that because people want lots of data to
train on and maybe it's that game
theoretic back-and-forth that gets us to
80/20 yeah do they ultimately use a
similar metric like you know it's almost
the same thing as an academic setting
would you have your training set or
training data and your test set and all
that jazz that's a great question and
you contribute I see Bill nodding my
first pass at this would be the answer
is yes but then one fascinating thing
that might happen to you is that your
incentives are switched
so in academia we would kind of like all
our systems to look good and maybe that
creates a bias for having them look
better than they are because that's the
way you get published in industry though
when you think about deploying a system
if you're if your neck is on the line
for that deployed system you might take
a much harder look at the kind of
evaluations you're doing to essentially
get a conservative number about how it's
going to perform and you might do much
more kind of like truly tailed out
testing on completely or you know
partially unrelated distributions so
that when you do deploy you're not fired
do other people who've worked in
industry want to comment on that it's an
interesting dynamic
incentives is complicated because like
on the one hand you want to get your
project out the door on the other hand
do you also want to keep your job
so you kind of have complete dating
incentives I think ultimately you want
evaluations which reflect the true
strength test split and using the same
kind of methodology that we use in in
academia is pretty pretty standard let's
change topics a little bit Oh another
question yeah it's there any point and
you say doing like a meta-study Oh like
all the major data sets in a given
domain and seeing what the best ratio of
chain test widths are how would you
define best I mean it would get
interesting very fast cuz yeah what do
you mean by best I guess like which one
offers the best validation performance
yeah I mean I answer is kind of yes like
if you could find a way to do this that
offer to Intel vut to the community so
that we made better decisions going
forward we would all benefit it's kind
of hard for me to see how we get the
ideals right I think part of it would be
you stating what your ideals were but
you do remind me that there's another
interesting thing you could do which is
related to these split sizes which is to
say okay I have my fixed test set and my
default is to use all the training data
but maybe you're advocating for a system
that really shines with very little data
in which case I think it would be smart
for you to do evaluations where you
reduce the amount of training data and
maybe what you're doing is showing that
okay for all the training data your
competitor wins but you can get by on
10% of the data your system is still
doing much better at that point than the
other competitor that could be
incredibly valuable because we never
have enough data and so we should in
some sense favor systems
can thrive in that sparse area yes what
you just described yes yeah yeah and I
think you've retired into like the
general feeling that we should make
efficient use of all the data that we
have yeah let's talk a bit about
baselines again kind of maybe stuff
we've been taking for granted but it's
nonetheless we're thinking about these
things first of all as I said before we
can never understand evaluation numbers
in NLP in isolation and I feel like you
get you get it from both sides here
because on the one hand if you just
tried to publish a number like my system
gets 0.95 or 0.99 even f1 on a data set
you might think that you had you just
declare victory by default right because
you've solved the task but what will
actually happen is that your reviewers
will say well obviously this is too easy
and then that can and that this is also
like related to that debugging
phenomenon that might be depressing
about NLP that if you get perfect
performance
you probably don't cheer but rather
think something is broken about my code
I can't be that good so even those
really good numbers require maybe human
level performance and then at the other
side of baseline on the other hand if
your system gets point six oh you might
despair but maybe it turns out that
humans aren't a whole lot better and
maybe the baseline is way below that in
which case that point six Oh might mark
real progress on the problem and that's
a clear case where we need contexts
where you do not want people defaulting
to what they think point six Oh means in
the context of classification or
something
so these baselines are really important
for building good arguments they
shouldn't be an afterthought but rather
pretty central to how you set up your
hypotheses and you can hear us
encouraging that with this protocol
document that baselines are really
important to building a good case and
the other thing that you can do is use
them to illuminate specific aspects of
the problem that you're studying or some
virtue of
your proposed system and I think we've
seen versions of this before we didn't
dwell on it but think like if I have a
model that's just summing glove vectors
it's completely insensitive to word
order if I compare that to a model like
an RNN which has a lot of word order
dependence and I show that the RNN is
better then I've got a kind of intuitive
indirect argument that word order
matters for my dataset and you can think
of lots of other examples that will have
that quality maybe you added some
attention mechanisms to your nli model
and then the difference you know the
gain that you get from that is kind of
illuminating the fact that there are
important kind of dependencies between
premise and hypothesis that a standard
model was just missing out on may be
forgotten but important to mention here
random baselines you might want to
include them and this is I mean often
the random baseline will be easy to
construct like you could just say I'm
gonna guess proportional to the class
label or I'm gonna just pick the
majority class those are two common
baselines I mentioned the dummy
classifier and dummy regressor here
these are both sidekick models just
because they make it easy for you to
build the dummy classifier into your
standard experimental pipeline so maybe
you're testing like five different
models you don't want to have a separate
code base for doing the dummy classifier
because it might you might introduce
bugs there or change the evaluation
somehow or it might make it just very
hard to make sure all your models are
seeing the same data with dummy
classifier and regressor they have the
same interface as all the other sidekick
models and in turn same interfaces all
the models that we've used for pi torch
and so forth in this class it's just
that they don't make intelligent use of
the features that you give them
essentially but that's kind of nice in
terms of automating your workflows this
is a subtler issue this is kind of
already pushing us beyond standard
thinking about evaluation I've called
this task specific baselines it's worth
considering whether your problems
suggest a baseline that will reveal
something about
the way the problem is posed or modeled
we've seen one example of this so in nli
we saw that hypothesis only base lines
can be very strong much stronger than
random guessing and I gave you an
argument for why that is I think there's
a scientific reason at least in part for
why these can be so strong another story
that had some prominence a few years ago
in some there's a story closed dataset
and this is where you are given a
passage and you have to choose between a
coherent and incoherent ending for that
passage and people reported a lot of
progress on this you know numbers that
look pretty good compared to human
performance but then it all kind of got
qualified by the fact that if you turn
to classify or loose just on the endings
without showing it the story it could
come pretty close to those top numbers
and I don't have such a hopeful story
about that one as I do about the nli
baseline this might indicate that
there's a real problem with the data set
but separately from that even if there
is an issue you can kind of partly
overcome that by just saying my base
line is this classifier that doesn't
look at the story it gets 70 percent and
then let's see how much further we can
get from that with a smart model and
more intelligent use of the data right
so all is not lost
even in a two type situation here yeah
that's a specific baseline do you is
essentially kind of implicitly encoding
some prior knowledge about probably in
doing that right do you think there's
any potential like risks when you take
that approach what would be the risks
that you'd be making the problem too
hard for yourself
I think I see what you mean so I don't
so do you think it holds for either of
these two just to get a feel for what
you're after
I recognize that it's a danger so don't
do it
I'm only partly partly joking in the
sense that if you do take this step it's
probably because you're giving a
positive argument that you feel random
is just not a fair baseline for us to
have picked that's certainly what you
would do in both of these situations I
guess I would be kind of discouraging
about just going off and seeing if you
can
cleverly construct task-specific
baselines that are really strong because
you might end up introducing biases of
the sort you're describing but a lot of
what I'm trying to do here is say I
don't have the full answer because I
don't know what the world is going to
throw at me what tasks you're going to
take on what your data will be like the
idea here is to just be thoughtful about
it and that like if you think about the
really exceptional papers in our field
they often have first of all they're
thoughtful about all their choices in my
experience but they often also introduce
these subtleties in a way that moves us
forward conceptually and not just
quantitatively okay another big topic is
hyper parameter optimization this is
where we're going to start using those
cloud credits I guess I gave this
argument before let me rehearse it and
amplify it a little bit so just for some
terminology here in machine learning the
parameters of your model are those whose
values are learned as part of our
optimizing the model itself we often
call those the weights or the
coefficients let's take that as given as
a definition and just say that the hyper
parameters of your model are any
settings that are set by a process that
is outside of the one that I described
under one of course the boundary between
these two could get blurred and moreover
if you think about the space that I just
defined for hyper parameters it could
end up including everything including
like what kind of computer you're
running on and what you had for
breakfast but
clear examples here the regularization
term for a classifier that's a clear
hyper parameter we all have an intuition
that those values could pretty
dramatically affect how your system
performs other examples are like the
dimensionality of your network if it's
deep learning the activation functions
that you use could have a huge impact
the optimizer that you could use could
have an impact especially for models
that don't converge in a reliable way
you could also think as I've done here
what about like the way you normalize
feature values did you apply tf-idf or
PSA or something like that we're kind of
drifting farther and farther from the
core parts of the model but I think you
could think of all these things as hyper
parameters and we'll construe them
pretty broadly so here's the rationale
for doing hyper parameter optimization
there are lots of ways you could go at
this but here I've picked one kind of
back and forth narrative so suppose you
ran experiments with models a B and C
and for each you use the default hyper
parameters as given by the
implementations you're using right so
inside key you just set up these models
you initialize them with no arguments
say I'm just at the mercy of what psych
it picked and in doing that you found
that your model C perform best and you
report that in your paper and you think
oh you know victory I was rooting for C
and it came out true your reviewer is
gonna ask or certainly wonder about a
few things so first did you actually try
any other values for the hyper
parameters without reporting that they
might just wonder about your practices
if not would you have done that if your
favorite model hadn't outperformed the
others perfectly legitimate question
right you maybe you didn't have to
confront it but suppose B had won your
competition would you have thought well
wait a second I need to think about
whether or not I'm doing the
regularization correctly let me fiddle
around with some values a little bit and
then you'd be off and running on some
hill climbing toward your favorite thing
so that what the reviewer might conclude
here is that all we've learned at this
stage is that there's some setting of
the hyper parameters that favors your
model and disfavors the other one but
the really cynical hard-bitten reviewer
is going to say well I already knew that
because I know that I
canjust craftily pick these settings in
a way that will make some model look
terrible and other models look good
right if I'm given this is kind of
behind the scenes fiddling then game
over we don't have a fair evaluation so
in response you could give every model
its best chance to succeed right let
your models explore a really wide range
of hyper parameters for each model
choose the best settings according to
performance on your development data and
then report how the models do on those
settings on all your test sets right if
you go through that whole discourse
there you're persistent reviewer might
say well you didn't pick the right space
of hyper parameters you should have gone
further you should have tried these new
variations and I grant that but I mean
come on we have to stop somewhere so
that's one kind of rationale the other
would be just that you are open-mindedly
trying to figure out what's best like
you've been placed in the situation
where you have to do a bake-off for a
class and you want to win and then all
these same dynamics kick in it's just
that you're not arguing with someone but
rather just trying to figure out how you
can win the bake-off I think the same
rationale applies because you want to
pick a B and C and really see each one
in the best possible light and that's
kind of the spirit of this that we get a
fair evaluation if we see a B and C all
at their best which means like dressing
them up to be the best they can be and
that comes back to the hyper parameters
so here's the ideal for this kind of
thing for each hyper parameter to your
model identify a really large set of
values for it create a list of all the
combinations of all the hyper parameter
values this will be the full
cross-product of all the sets of values
for all the features you identified as
relevant for each of the settings cross
validate it on the available training
data and then choose the settings that
did best trained on all the data and
then evaluate your model in the usual
way so that's what you're really ought
to be doing I suppose by the logic that
I gave you before however this could be
very demanding suppose that I
parameter one has five values and two
has ten okay now there are fifty
settings if you add a third with two
values now your number of settings has
jumped to a hundred okay now you want to
do five fold cross validation that means
you're doing 500 runs and if you want to
do ten random train test splits because
you want to like test whether or not
your model is statistically different or
look at confidence intervals now you're
doing five thousand runs of your model
boy that got expensive fast right and if
each one of these models takes eight
hours of GPU compute time well you can
do the numbers here because it's gonna
get very expensive yeah we have to we
have to back off from this I deal a
little bit this is untenable as a set of
laws for a scientific community if we
actually said that the only people who
could publish were people who had made
good on this entire thing here then only
people with vast amounts of money would
be able to publish it all and in
addition we would have a distorting bias
in favor of simple models because those
would be the models that you could
really afford to do all these runs for
and I picked this their more and more
you see these kind of things but this is
from a nice paper on doing NLP for
healthcare and they just note in their
methods section in an appendix the
performance of all above neural networks
were tuned automatically using Google
Vizier with a total of over 200,000 GPU
hours so you figure like okay at $1 an
hour plus whatever Google is going to
take from me this could cost a quarter
of a million dollars very easily we got
you some amazon credits but not close to
that
I'm afraid so we can't have that be the
the law that we live by we can have it
as an ideal but we shouldn't allow
others to expect it from us nor should
we work wire of other people we need to
introduce some space for being pragmatic
about these choices so here is my view
about how we could kind of alleviate
this problem and I've done this again
this is very impressionistic but in
descending order of attractiveness to me
as a reviewer or
to my imagined reviewers out there if I
think about them being antagonists for
me so first you could do some random
random sampling and guided sampling to
allow your to explore a really large
space based on a fixed budget of runs so
the random sampling part would be just
that I set up my grid as I did before
and it has 500 settings but I decide
that I'm gonna look at 50 of them and
what the random sample err will do is
pick 50 random settings and what I'll do
is kind of have an expectation that
that's a pretty good sample of the full
space that I with only low probability
missed a setting that was going to be
really transformative lis different and
then there's a kind of variation on that
that it's called I've called guided
sampling here which would be that you
have maybe a separate model running that
is trying to intelligently travel around
in the hyper parameter space and make
choices on that basis and you might
think that that's better than random the
virtue of both of these strategies is
you could just say look my budget is 50
runs and that you won't and having in
doing that have to delimit your hyper
parameter space artificially because it
could be wide and you're still just
going to sample 50 times from it and I
think this is pretty palatable to
reviewers especially since there's
published evidence that random sampling
is a good strategy and I included those
links in the notebook on the website and
then guided sampling is another proven
method and I'll show you I'll link to
you some software packages for doing
that a little bit later is that the like
space of hyper parameters is really
nonlinear that's a great question I
think it really is going to depend on
your model and your settings yeah do you
have anything more to say
the task you actually have like very
very convenient you really want to
especially that something like random
sampling with an evening which is this
idea that you keep focusing on small
areas as as you are advancing on the
process of finding HEPA parameters to
you and you'll have to explore all we
can say behavior but you can kind of
train yourself this smaller smaller
smaller area and then you you see that
you get have like new games but it's
based on these you know we've talked
about the second strategy before I'm
sorry that these are all ones here you
could do some search based on a few
epochs of training so this is especially
relevant I think in the context of deep
learning models where your model may
take a thousand epochs to converge and
that would be very expensive to do all
those runs and then check performance
and select parameters on that basis but
what you could do is have a background
hypothesis that the future is going to
be like the past that a setting that was
really bad at the start is just going to
remain bad and in turn settings that are
good in the start are going to remain
good two things about that you might not
be able to prove it but you might be
able to support it with some kind of
learning curves that show what's
happening in those early things and
maybe a few runs that project out
further and show that your assumption is
basically correct so you could do that
to kind of build your case but you know
if you don't have the capacity to do
that even just acknowledging that this
is the strategy that you picked and
giving a reason based on budget or other
considerations I think will go a long
way with reviewers because it kind of
acknowledges that your choices were done
on somewhat limited evidence but at
least you know that that qualification
exists and again this is kind of nice
because you can control costs in this
way while still exploring a large
space of parameters search based on
subsets of the data that's another
strategy that we explored off and on
throughout this course and that would be
that you know my actual data set
contains five hundred thousand examples
but I'll do my tuning on five thousand
and then I have lots of flexibility to
do lots of experiments and then I'll
just project that out to the larger set
the real problem with that is that I
think it's obvious that some of these
parameters these hyper parameters could
be very dependent on data set size so a
classic case would be that
regularization parameters are really
going to be affected by the number of
features you have and the amount of
evidence that you can gather for each
one and that's interacting badly with
this approach to selection but still
certainly better than nothing you could
also do some heuristic search we're
getting kind of low down in this list
but this is still quite respectable
right so via some experiments that you
run just in a free-form way you figure
out that some hyper parameters never
change performance and others really
change it a lot and in turn you just fix
the ones that seem not to matter and
explore the rest and this would be a
case where absolutely you would want to
justify this in the paper you'd want to
say that for our problem the
dimensionality of the hidden layer
didn't matter in the range 50 to 300 so
we said it at 300 and explored all the
regularization parameters and then you
know your reviewer could say in my
experience the hidden dimensionality
really matters but now it's kind of on
them to have that evidence right and you
sort of said heuristic aliy that you
didn't see it
so I don't know it seems like you built
a pretty good argument in that case you
could find the optimal hyperplane then
use them for all subsequent splits and
this would be justified on the idea that
the splits are similar so that would be
a case of saying like I'm going to run
one experiment really carefully and
assume that it holds for all the other
settings that I need to explore that
could be pretty reasonable with a large
data set that you know is kind of Hammad
this this is probably perfectly fine and
then all the way at the bottom here but
something that you still do see is just
adopting choices that other people have
made so you know like I'm gonna train
new word vectors on a bajillion words
from the web and I don't know how this
model is going to behave I can afford to
run one experiment so I'm just gonna
pick the parameters that were in the
originally published paper and use them
even though the data is different and my
goals are different and so forth you're
probably going to get some complaints
that the findings don't translate that
what was optimal for that paper isn't
necessarily optimal for yours
but in that setting where you're trying
to do web-scale training of word
representations this might be all you
can afford and again I think we can't
just arbitrarily expect that people will
run multiple runs across the whole web
in order to tune these parameters so as
the last resort other people's
parameters and there's lots of papers
that do this and I think it works out ok
yeah the best results on some data set
is it to justify all this I mean if you
know let's just say you just stuff some
overs out of your out of your hat and
they work the best do you still have to
say I did all of this stuff or is that
almost not self sufficient evidence that
you're eating the benchmark we're the
way the paper is really one of these
pure papers that just says my model is
the best model for this data set and my
evidence is that I found parameter
settings that beat all the published
numbers it might be a persuasive
argument yeah I mean I personally would
hope that you're trying to do more with
this paper and if you were trying to
show us something more about this model
than just that you won then this would
all kick in because I'd want to
understand like what's the space of
performance numbers and so forth some of
this I'm going to address in a little
bit but yeah I want to allow them that
might be all that's necessary sort of
robustness to different hyper parameters
at least trying a lot of them give you
more insight into how the models working
I mean ultimately if you have a good
hypothesis
the results are promising why is it
necessary to really get that last little
bit of juice out of your model by hyper
Prevnar soldier oh I see it might not be
juice like at first I want to just grant
that your narrative might be perfectly
fine which is just that you know I found
a setting where my model is the best and
that's evidence that it's a really good
model for the task the hyper perimeter
exploration might be something that you
explore more openly to say for example
how small could my network get and still
do well how what are my performance
drop-offs or how much does it matter how
it was regularized or like how much does
it matter even how it was initialized
with glove or with word Tyvek or with
Elmo
and what I was just injecting my values
there that I find all of that really
illuminating because after all I don't
really care that you won I mean
congratulations in this case that you
won but what I really want to know is
can I use your model for other tasks how
sensitive is it to various settings can
I form an expectation about how it will
work in an entirely new domain that kind
of thing here's some hyper parameter
optimization tool so psych it has grid
search and randomize search Goods
standbys here and randomized search will
be the one where you can fix your budget
and then socket optimizes a package for
doing more guided search through these
spaces and it's kind of nice because it
plays well with the existing psychic
models and it might offer you some
additional gains when you do this kind
of thing on a fixed budget let's do one
more thing here classify our comparison
because we've seen this before this is a
nice way to round out this first lecture
so suppose you've assessed two
classifier models well we'll keep it for
two classifiers because I think a lot of
you are doing classifiers these same
considerations extend to other kinds of
models and we can talk about how that
would work would work but suppose it's
classifiers
they probably differ in some way what
could we do to establish that they're
different in some meaningful sense and
again if you think about publish
reviewers will ask this how much can I
trust that differences I'm seeing are
really in truly differences so first of
all you might think practical
differences this is the ultimate right
if your test set has a thousand so if
you say if your test set has a million
examples then one percent will
correspond to ten thousand cases and
that seems like it's sure to matter
right if this is live saved or something
or disastrous consequences averted
then ten thousand you shouldn't need to
say much more than that you're making a
meaningful impact on the world right so
there's that one case in the other case
if the test set has a thousand examples
then a one percent difference in
accuracy or f1 will be like ten examples
and your readers might not know whether
that matters at all and then hovering in
the background here is this other
question how much variation is there
across runs that is in the case where it
was ten examples for your reported
number if I make a small change does it
go in the other direction right it seems
like it's just on the edge and in
principle that could be true even of
these models here because maybe with
some runs you saved ten thousand lives
but in others you lose five thousand we
don't know right because we don't know
the amount of variation there is between
runs for your system and so all those
things mean that we probably want to go
beyond just practical differences so
just quickly a few ways you could do
this first you could report confidence
intervals around the means that you
report I've given your a kind of
traditional way to do this that you
could use my sense from NLP systems is
that this traditional way here is pretty
conservative in the sense that your
system might actually show less
variation than is being assumed by this
test and so you might see confidence
intervals that show values that are way
outside anything you've ever seen in
running experiments if that happens you
could think about bootstrapping the
confidence intervals and I link to a
library for doing that and that will
just make much more use of your actual
data when it comes to deciding what the
interval of variation is but this is a
really nice way to do this you report
the mean and the confidence interval and
what your reviewers are likely to do is
say okay those two intervals don't
overlap I'm pretty confident that these
systems are different or if there's a
lot of overlap you might say hmm you
know numerically they're different but
in practical terms these might be the
same system so this is a powerful step
but it presupposes that you can do a lot
of runs because you want to do like ten
and you know better would be like 20
different runs to get a bunch of values
for the mean in slightly different
scenario settings so that you can get a
good picture of what the confidence
interval is like and you might just be
limited in your ability to do that
related kind of thing that you could do
then and again I'm just kind of drawing
on best practices as I've learned them
from the literature is to run the
wilcoxon signed-rank test which is a
kind of variant of a t-test that doesn't
make any assumptions about the
underlying statistical distribution so
it does not presuppose in particular
that your scores are normally
distributed it requires a lot of
different runs so you want to do at
least ten ideally 20 or something like
that
I think that you want to pick the
wilcoxon signed-rank test over this very
closely related one the ranked sums test
which is often called the men Whitney
you test
I think the wilcoxon one will be just
slightly more conservative in the sense
that it's more appropriate in situations
in which your systems are trained and
evaluated on the same underlying data
and given the best practices as I laid
out before you want them to be trained
and test on the same data for these
comparisons but that just means that you
violated a lot of Independence
assumptions so pick the well Coxon
signed-rank test it's a ranked big test
so it all it's caring about is the
relative ordering of the scores that
your system reports I think this is a
good step to take and I think it will go
a long way to people up for people who
are evaluating your work but a few
qualifications are in order first like
all tests of this form it says nothing
about the
practical importance --is of any of the
differences that you see so like a small
p-value is not a larger effect size and
a large p-value doesn't mean that you
have a failed result it just means that
you lack evidence for claiming that
there's a difference so these
qualifications are to be kept in mind
this is kind of very weak evidence for
some kind of detectable difference but I
would ideally balance it against
something establishing that your systems
are different in practical terms but I
grant you that this could help you in
sort of advocating for a system
especially in situations in which the
numerical differences appear to be small
because here you're saying they're small
but I have some evidence that you can
count on them and then just a final test
so we can wrap this up here McNee Mars
test is a test that you can run to
compare two classifiers that depends
only on one run of the data because it
operates on this kind of collapsed
confusion matrix for your two systems
and it's a kind of variant of the
chi-squared test I think that this is
can be pretty volatile for systems that
report different values under different
conditions so I would resort to this
just in situations in which you
absolutely cannot afford to do the
number of runs that it would take to run
a responsible wilcoxon test in this case
this is a kind of fallback I think again
it's better than nothing for your
reviewers and especially if you can
compare if you can pair it with
practical differences you've probably
got a pretty good case for the models
being different there are a bunch of
other big issues that I want us to
confront that are kind of particular to
the deep learning era but since we're
out of time I'm going to save those for
next time so next time it'll be these
juicy issues that we're all facing today
a discussion of metrics and then this is
going to take us beyond all this
traditional stuff that I've been talking
about well thanks everyone for your
questions